[Musik]
interessante black ops staffel
ich bin da franz reisecker meine dienst
gratis major-event oder staffel
kommandant und in immer härter mit auf
einen rundgang herr und um meinen black
hawk wir bereiten uns vor für den
flugdienst und das erste der pilot zu
tun hat ist an außen check zu machen und
deswegen immer unter uns mit begehrtes
räume und ich sage euch die dinge die
immer kontrolliert vor einem flug da
vorne ist der einstiegstüren das ist die
kultur für den copiloten da kann man
schon mal einen ersten blick wagen ins
cockpit
da schauen wir nur ob die tür richtig
auf und erklärt ob alle verriegelungen
zu sein
unterstelle man gern mal bei den
schneebrettern die jetzt natürlich um
diese jahreszeit sollen die
schneebretter montiert und gecheckt mal
ob die richtig montiert sein
da gibt es so prüft marken und da
schauen wir ob alles richtig montiert
wurde von der technik und die
schneebretter wir fliegen natürlich ein
hochgebirge mit diesen hubschraubern und
dort das vista server vom skifahren gibt
es oft an tiefschnee und damit man dort
irgendwo landen können haben wir
natürlich ziemlich mächtige
schneebretter die fast so groß sein wie
das surfbrett aber sie dürfen uns bei
der arbeit so wir schauen weiter noch
einmal die kabinentüren auf
dann steige einmal darauf wann kann man
kann den ersten blick wagen in die
kabine ist relativ viel platz da drin
man kann bis zu 20 17 montieren wenn man
soldaten methoden mit ausrüstung dann
wird man natürlich april weniger sitze
rein wir einfach nicht so viel platz es
dann in der version haben wir jetzt acht
sitzplätze für 2000 wie gesagt bis zu 20
kann man einfach die steiger mal darauf
war blick zum linken triebwerk wo man
den ölstand kontrolliert ja warum linke
triebwerk wir um zwei triebwerke jeweils
1940 ps dass wir uns in der luft halten
ja und zwar gerade bei der kabine sind
möchte etwas tagen nämlich daher in
reinkommt motto erkennen ist wirklich
ein im boden
da ist der außenbeauftragten versteckt
den kann man da so ausklappen und da
kann man bis zu vier tonnen außen last
anhängern für militärische geschichten
kommando kfz autos sonst du hast
transportieren außen an hängen oder im
assistenzeinsatz im katastropheneinsatz
kammer auch bagger haben wir schon
angehängt und auch von ihnen täglich
geflogen oder sogar ein container kann
punktgenau im gebirge absetzen
das bedarf natürlich einer guten
zusammenarbeit mit dem techniker da
hinten wir haben zwei bord techniker mit
und wer weiß denn piloten weil wir sind
natürlich nicht nur noch hinten
er weiß den punkt genau hin bei der
aufnahme von der last und beim aufsetzen
von der last aber da braucht man
natürlich ein bisschen training und das
machen
[Musik]
wie gesagt das land gedreht wird da wird
der sprit ein geschulter schauen wir nur
ob zu ist wir können
2300 punkt springt einladen das reicht
locker für zweieinhalb stunden flugzeit
damit kommen um die 500 kilometer weit
das überprüfen wir gehen weiter dieses
ganze gesteigert hat man den auslass von
vom linken triebwerk da jetzt natürlich
relativ warm in der gegend weil dort die
heiße luft rauskommt
da hat man gleich das zusatz triebwerk
ich habe bis jetzt von zwei triebwerken
gesprochen wir haben über twitter mit
thema quasi die haupttriebwerke anlassen
strom machen setzen können und der
flughafen aus los ist auf der linken
seite und co
draußen dann gehen wir stück weiter da
sieht man schon mal das stadthaus wer
treppengeländer ist aber antenne für die
vielen funkgeräte thema mittlerweile
weil wir stehen ja jetzt bei dem
hubschrauber bei den black hawk mit
einem neuen cockpit
das wären wir uns dann später noch
anschauen aber der hat aber andere
antennen nur zusätzlich darf weil er
mehr funkgeräte trend fort dass wir
haben unsere im detail anschauen
wir haben ein räderwerk wie er schon
gehabt und natürlich auch das hintere
rad braucht wenn man im hochgebirge land
ein schneebrett das ist ein bisschen
kleiner ausgeführt doch schauen wir
einfach obwohl markierungen passen das
rad verriegelt ist die öl stände und
dann kommen dort zusammen mächtigen
schaut aus der tragflächen ns-täter und
ist das einzige teil bei diesem
hubschrauber fly by wire
das heißt der wird gesteuert vom
computer je schneller man fliegt desto
horizontaler steht das ding und je
langsamer desto weiter unten steht der
blätter und der soll quasi den
hubschrauber stabil stabilisieren im nig
moment weil er einfach ein
geschwindigkeitsbereich zwischen 0 und
maximal 360 km/h hat und damit der
trotzdem immer halbwegs gerade in der
luft liegt braucht er dieses level damit
man keine wurzeln machen und der
stabilisiert den ganzen hubschrauber
hinten der heckrotor auch ein mächtiges
gerät leicht schräg gestellt wie ihr
sehen könnt ist ebenfalls damit ihm
schweben nachdem der hubschrauber so
lange ist nicht in einer position also
nach hinten geneigt ständig dabei
sondern der heckrotor in dem fall
produzierter bislang auftritt damit sie
schön gerade im schweben in der luft
stehen kann
wir überprüfen das öl stände solche
dinge gehen dann vorbei bei den anderen
antennen für navigation gps antennen
wir haben natürlich auch verbindung zum
satelliten
damit man navigieren können und auch
anflüge machen können
diese komische beule da der blackrock
ist natürlich ein militärhubschrauber
das habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon
gegoogelt oder irgendwo mitgewirkt
das heißt der kanal in gefährlichen
umfeld fliegen und da unter anderem kann
man an jeff und flirte spencer montieren
da kann man magnesium fackeln heiße
fackeln zerstörung von infrarot
lenkwaffe ausstoßen oder heute
zerstörung von irgendwelchen gerader
gelenkten waffen ja chef und flirte
spencer hat das drin und da kommen die
patronen rein und das schießt links und
rechts raus so jetzt haben beim rechten
triebwerk angekommen so checkt man
einmal die öl stände und kabinen für ob
alles in ordnung ist so dieser komische
stehen hüter der ist nur auf der rechten
seite da kann man rettungswinde
montieren
die bis zu 80 meter seil drauf hat und
wo man zwei personen anhängen kann die
kamera retten irgendwas im gebirge von
einem schiff von einem brennenden
hochhaus was auch immer wir haben das
auch schon trainiert von
eisenbahnwaggons herunter von von einem
boot heraus also auch eine gute
möglichkeit irgendwo ein beitrag zu
leisten
von janna berta
ich habe es zuerst schon angesprochen
wir haben natürlich bord techniker mit
normalerweise beim blecker kann man 2
port techniker mit und so ist der ein-
und ausstieg sluka für den board
techniker der hüfte rein und da ist sein
arbeitsplatz
wir haben doch so gerne löcher
verfassungen da kann man die
maschinengewehre montieren natürlich
kann man aus dem militär hubschrauber
blackrock auch links und rechts eine
bewaffnung darauf geben wie sie in
unserem fall blase selbstschutz
bewaffnung gedacht und die bordtechnik
als sind gleichzeitig auch durch ghana
und die können uns dort einen gewissen
schutz gewährleisten
auf beiden seiten und kontrollieren
weiter bis ganz nach vorn wir haben
natürlich auch scheibenwischer eines
regen hat braucht man das beschreiben
sind auch beheizbar
wie bei den modernen autos man kann mit
dem blackrock auch an instrumentenflug
machen das heißt man fliegt den wolken
durch die gegentreffer geführt
und da kann es zur vereisung kommen in
diesen wolken monsters und damit man die
scheibe eine ganz zufriert kann man die
beheizen und das gleich auch bei den
haupt rotorblättern und beim headquarter
kann man die heizung einschalten und das
eis wird damit quasi mit der entfernt so
und jetzt kommt ganz nach vorn haben sie
viele wahrscheinlich schon folgt wusste
sie ist das ist weder was zum fürsten
nur als verzierung gedacht da drin ist
mit dem speziellen instrumentenflug
einfach alle wettererscheinungen
niederschläge gewitter und solche dinge
in einer reichweite von über 500
kilometer vor uns quasi auf dem
bildschirm zur anzeige bringen damit der
pilot weiß was auf ihn zukommt oder wir
heute ausweichen kann
dafür ist das wetter weiter so und jetzt
kommt jetzt schauen wir einen sprung ins
cockpit
ja schön dass hier dabei sagt wir sind
jetzt im
cockpit angekommen und wir sitzen hier
im ersten break der mit dem neuen
komplett ausgestattet und die wäre ich
jetzt ein paar dinge erzählen die bei
ertönen der ja es wurden im neuen
cockpit zwar verschiedene systeme
eingebaut
vorne sind vier bildschirme mit den
komposthaufen es ist ein kamen komplett
und zwar das kamen 5000 ein ziviles
system sind immer fliegt und dass
zweitens nachdem wir natürlich in
mellenthin herum schauen was man haben
wir noch ein militärischer system
eingebaut ist jetzt ausgeschaltet ist
in der staffel einen planungs computer
wird während der missionen die aufträge
getan den taktischen karten gespielt
das kann man das militärische system
einspielen über speicherkarten und es
seien mittlerweile sd cards
das wird dann auf dem zivilen kamen
system vorher auf den bildschirmen der
anteil gebracht
wir haben doch waren vier bildschirme
für jeden piloten 2
es winken ist jetzt direkt vor williams
dieser bildschirm ist das primaries play
mit dem flug instrument
den hubschrauber steuer und navigieren
wenn der bildschirm ist das mainfranken
display einerseits die tritte
überwachungsinstrumente haben
präsenz in verschiedenen
segmenten wir aussuchen kann welche
karten spielen will und das steuer mit
einem touchscreen eine auswählen welche
karte ihrer anteile im auto kann man das
machen nehmen mit dem militärischen
system wir spielen dort in taktischen
kamen
ja das ist es was neues ist alt
das alter sondern wirklich ihr steuer
organe mit denen die den schoß legen
kann ihr habt zwei bezahle ich hab damit
wären steuerknüppel mitnehmen vor zurück
ins nichts anfangen
auf der linken seite oder den kollekten
immer dann hoch
zwar steigen und sinken kann nach oben
gibt es dann nur die steuerungs hebel
für die drei werke
rehberger und starten
viele schalten beleuchtung hinstellen
kann und solche dinge
das problem stellen kann
und da lässt man braucht besonders
behinderten müssen
alle sicherungen
die normalen flug
und wenn ihr etat los bekommen wird
militär pilot zu werden
dann wird man uns über junge motivierte
mitarbeiter freuen
ihr kennt sich informieren auf der
internetseite karriere punkt bundesheer
punktete mit mir freuen
[Musik]